that's this for this thing because you
did the birthday too you did a lot of
things who before who for so who paid
for my birthday party if you're looking
at it or we all did oh that you guys all
did yeah so the company did the company
okay because i was feeling bad about it
because that must have been expensive no
it's a birthday it's your favorite
celebration did we talk about that
i talked about the birthday right we
haven't even told like what oh yeah you
didn't even talk about we haven't talked
about i don't even post a video oh we
haven't talked to the birthday party oh
it was the most magical party i can only
imagine
magical did you know about the party
absolutely not were you truly surprised
yes 100
i thought um
you said
well it's what i didn't know about the
um party and then you were like thursday
you were like i go
i called you i go sterling's in town
and then you slyly god oh let's go have
dinner with them tomorrow at six
right so that little thing made it seem
like it was that she made it up right
then or a minute last minute right smart
so you wouldn't think anything of it
right and then but here's what could
have given it away
was when you said when i the next day i
said
gina gershon is in town and you're like
i just invite her to the dinner right in
my head at split second it was weird
like
it's an intimate thing with me you
sterling and his girlfriend you know
what i mean so why would you invite gina
right because you were like oh she's so
great i was like oh yeah yeah maybe
you're right and you were right because
she was amazing and we had a blast yeah
so i we go to choson and i go around the
corner
and i just i was like i was hit by a
train i couldn't believe it i was so
delighted
because there you see
everyone
that i wanted to see at that very moment
no but i i go and i looked at everyone i
was like um wow what a great thing
and then um
and then we ate and then the show
afterwards was even more magical we all
went to that
show in koreatown dumbfounded show
and that's where i saw benedict and
aquafina and everybody aquafina brought
me up on stage and they got a cake for
you she's gotta be cake for me it was
just a really
cool
night and um
i don't know i uh
it was really it really was one of those
like so chill perfect evenings i think
it didn't seem forced or anything what's
the matter yeah
it was great
thank you so much are you emotional
about it yeah
yeah i'm emotional about it yeah um 50
is a hard one
it really is it makes it hard
i might have i mean am i having a
mid-life crisis
in what way i don't know
i feel like you know when um neil peart
knew neil purdes
no thanks you guys know who neil pearl
is don't look it up i'll tell you what
it is i don't know what it looks like
neil pert was a drummer one of the
greatest drummers of all time
um he was the drummer for rush oh yes of
course okay so neil pert i love rush
had a couple of tragedies happen you
know i think his daughter died
and then his um
wife died right after that
and he
just got i don't ride motorcycles but he
got on his motorcycle and he just drove
for four years
like
the band didn't play
i mean he was the only way they knew
where he was was postcards
so he'd be like somewhere in south
america
on his motorcycle and there would be a
postcard from some small little
dinky town i mean that he's staying at
you know what i mean and he didn't um
talk to anybody
he just rode into the
you know i mean into the night
for four years and then one day
he just shows back up
four or five years later and he goes i
think i'm ready to play now right now do
you think that that was a crisis or
a freeing of his soul like that doesn't
sound like a crisis it sounds like a man
i think when they say midlife crisis i i
don't really agree i just think that
it's like i um
i feel like you know i need
you know i mean to do something drastic
almost like you know in terms of
my career or
you know i mean just little fantasies
that i have of like
you know
just riding a motorcycle into a
town what
you wear a cowboy hat you know you know
what i've always with a bell puckle
suspenders i've always wanted to just go
in an rv with you and the animals and
like that'd be fun dive deep into yeah
america that'd be fun something like
that though where it's like you know
i'm just you know what i was where was i
i was in
what town was i in i was in
wisconsin or one of these uh i don't
know it was wisconsin i got to figure
out what i was just sorry i'll just give
me a second
i was in either
[Music]
um where's wiseguys at
oh it's salt lake no it wasn't salt lake
i think it was somewhere no you know
what no i know where it was it was omaha
nebraska okay i was in omaha nebraska
and i was in this weird
coffee shop right in some mall but now
it wasn't only a mall like structure
and it was hard to find it's like you
have to go down this like viney tunnel
and then like you walked in there and
you could tell this coffee shop had been
there for like 40 years i mean it was
just old
and um
i just sat there and had a coffee and it
looked like i felt like i was in a
different
time period or you know even
country you know it felt
different and i remember sitting there
for hours i was writing
you know and it was just like
and the people that would walk in were
people that i normally don't see you
know i mean people from a different era
almost
right and it was almost like really cool
and it was one of those things too is
like they don't know who you are like no
one knows who i am
not that i'm famous now like i can still
walk around l.a no one knows who i am no
that's not true are you crazy there are
some places in la i if i go to like
koreatown people know who i am you know
what i mean you know i mean different
places west hollywood i'll always get
somebody you know what i mean but like
this place was like no like they would
just look at me like i'm just like
student
like foreign exchange student or
whatever like they don't know
right like i could be just like how do i
you know make an accent yeah and they'd
be like oh where are you from i could
just make up a whole different character
yeah and like you know and it's also you
know what you know
there's like when you order coffee from
a place like that they're just really
kind not because you're somebody
that's just what they are
right whereas here it's like sometimes
i'll go i hope the waiter or
you know
the guy behind the counter recognizes me
so i get treated nice
do you want what i'm saying yeah that
makes sense yeah it's just one of those
things that i'm
that's a memory
and an experience that i long for you
know
but 50 is a big one because you think
you start thinking oh diego maradona
died at 60.
norm just died at 62 right and you start
thinking do i have 10 years left
i know but i mean you don't know
who knows right
but it's like
most of it's gone that's an obvious
that's a truth
right most of it's gone i'm not the
healthiest guy in the world so you just
start thinking
and then when you're thinking there's
not a lot of time left there's something
about you that's
like what do i i want to do ayahuasca or
whatever you know i mean you start
thinking
i know i brought the [ __ ]
did i bring everyone down can we tiger
belly overseas that's what i want to do
is like in a couple years just move to
some small like
move to some place overseas
do the same thing but we live in a
completely different environment
yeah if i i might move to you know i
might gotta i might gotta i i think i
might have gotten a job in new york so
that's gonna take me there for five
months i mean we could do tiger belly
there maybe that'll you know i mean the
kind of guests will get
is completely different right do you
ever think of taking
you're seeing yourself taking a
sabbatical from all entertainment like
those actors that go like dave chappelle
like do you see a whole year could you
do that without this industry and do
everything you talked about i think i
could i think that i could um
i want to learn how to pick
you you know what you really do yeah
let's start with you learning how to
cook rice because you're asian no bake
i go rice first you gotta learn you got
to learn go for the gold
yeah yeah yeah i want to learn how to
bank i think you'd be great i want to
make clogs i don't know what that is
like clogs shoes oh my god when is the
um greatest of the british bake off the
new um our two episodes are already so
[ __ ] i'm behind on everything
yeah that was the weirdest
recommendation after squid game it was
like how about the great british bake
you know what it makes sense